we're on problem 24.
use the solution procedure below to
answer the question that follows which
of the following is a major flaw in the
procedure shown above so let's look for
some flaws
so the way i always like to do is just
think about how i would have done it so
if i started with minus 3x
plus 25 is equal to 4 the first thing i
would do is subtract 25 from both sides
of the equation
so i would take a
minus 25 from the left hand side and
then a minus 25 from the right hand side
it looks like that's what the person did
took a minus 25 there and he took a
minus 25
just like that and then he said okay
well that's the same thing as minus 21.
so then you would get you would get
minus 3x on the left-hand side is equal
to minus 21. i have a sense that i
already know what the major flaw is he's
doing two steps and he's not writing a
nice clean equality and he's trying to
skip steps and my guess is that he's
going to get confused so then you end up
with minus 3x on the left-hand side
right because these cancel out minus 3x
is equal to minus 21 so you get that
so you get that right there so you get
minus 3x is equal to minus 21 and then
you divide both sides by minus 3
and you get x is equal to 7. so the guy
got the right answer
however he or she may have done it but
this is a little confusing because then
divides by three but you know this
divide by minus three which you do have
to do you have to do to both sides of
this equation i just don't see where he
or she did it maybe you know somehow
just divided by -3 randomly i don't know
why they didn't they didn't really
understand the notion of inequality on
an equation that you have to do the same
thing to both sides of the both sides of
this equation so let's see what they
what the choices are the concept of the
opposite number is confused with
subtraction no not really the equal sign
is used to connect expressions that are
not
equal that sounds about right because
this expression
that expression and this
are equal we got minus 3x plus 25 minus
25 which is just minus 3x that does
indeed equal 4 minus 25 or minus 21. but
that does not equal minus 21 divided by
-3 so this looks like my answer let's
look at the other choices the solution
contains an error in the arithmetic of
signed numbers well no the solution the
solution
is the arithmetically arithmetically
correct indeed the order of operations
between subtraction division is reversed
so i don't really i really don't see
that so
my choice would be b they don't the
equal sign this
right here does not equal
this
right over there
next problem 25 use the diagram below to
answer the question that follows let's
see they're extending by one in each
direction they're kind of creating this
triangle if the pattern continues how
many more small squares are in figure
100 than are in figure
99 so let's think every time we
increment it how many squares are we
adding when we go from one to two how
many did we add we added one two squares
we went from two to three how many did
we add we had one two three squares we
went from three to four how many did we
add we had one two three four squares
those are the four that are the we kind
of layered over the three right there so
when we go from 100 to 99. so when we go
from 99 to 100 we're gonna add a hundred
squares
we're gonna add 100 squares when we go
from when we go from n to n plus one we
go from n to n plus 1 we add
we're adding n plus 1 squares so you go
from 99 to 100 you add 100 squares or
there are 100 more squares in the 100
figure than in the 99 figure
next problem
next problem all right
problem 26
use the table below to answer the
question that follows can you have an
x-axis and then we have a y-axis
and what do they want us to do
each number in the table above
represents a value of w that is
determined by the values of integers x
and y
for example when x equals 2
y equals 1
w
is equal to 21.
if the pattern continues what is the
value of w when x is equal to 20
when x is equal to 20 and y
y is equal to
8. so let's see if we can get a sense of
what w is or so w if you remember your
functions w is a function of i could
write it like that as a function of x
and y that might confuse you it may or
may not we just have to figure out what
this function is so if you look at this
pattern every time we look here we go
so this is zero to eight so and then we
go from
eight to sixteen so this is we're adding
eight every time we go to the right
we're adding eight right it looks like
we are and then as we go up what are we
doing so this is plus eight this is plus
eight so for example this right here is
this right here is four times eight this
is three times eight so i'm so it looks
like w is equal to eight
times x but then as you go up what
happens
as you go up
when you go up we're adding 5 every time
is that throughout the whole table yeah
sure 37 plus 5 is 42. we add 5 every
time and we start here at just 8 times x
and then when y is 0 and then we add 1
times 5 2 times 5 looks like it's 8x
plus
5y that's what w is right let's verify
it if we pick the point 3
so that would be w is equal to 8 times 3
plus 5 times 2
5 times 2. so w is equal to 24 plus 10
is equal to 34 which is indeed what it
equals so we found our function of x and
y and what are they asking the pattern
continues what is the value of when x is
equal to 20 and y is equal to 8. well in
that situation
w is equal to 8 times x which is 20
plus 5 times y which is 8 which is equal
to 160
plus 40 which is equal to
200 and that is choice b
next problem
problem
27 the function r of x gives the
remainder
gives the remainder when a whole number
x is divided by 10. all right when a
whole number okay which of the following
graphs represents r of x
so when you take something on the x axis
and divide it by 10 r of x should be its
remainder so you take 5 divided by 10
the remainder is 5. so we should it
should plot out to be a 5 right there we
take 10 divided by
your answer is well the answer is 1 and
your remainder is 0. so that looks right
and then 15 the remainder is 5. so those
look right let's see when you when you
plot when you have 1 1 divided by 5 1
divided by sorry 1 divided by 10 the
remainder is 1. so that looks right this
graph a looks pretty good if you take
you know 20 divided by 10 the remainder
is 0. if you take if you take 30 divided
by 10 the remainder is here if you take
29 divided by 10 the remainder is 9.
it's right there 19 divided by 9 the 10
remainder is 9. 9 divided by 10
remainder is 9. this one looks pretty
good let's see what the other ones do
so here let's see
when i take
divided by 10 the remainder should be
zero this should be a zero right here
but they have it the remainder being 10.
so this is wrong right off the bat
and then here
the remainder when a whole number x is
divided by this is a whole number
right whole number x
here they're doing it for essentially
all of the real numbers right this would
be true if they said any real number but
they're they're including fractions
because they're filling in the gaps
right here so c
and d are not dealing with whole numbers
so our answer is definitely is
definitely a